fortunate thing for black people is that
you have blm and the virtuous use of
donations
that can keep everything on track you
don't need to worry
daddy's in the hot seat absolutely how
many mansions does that girl who started
that woman who started to have now she's
left now right the first lady that did
it last one who's got the five mansions
silent oh very sort of quietly
slipped away i saw
after the news story about the six
million dollar mansion came out do you
see that there was an internal memo
leaked oh about this go on so an
internal memo got circulated uh in an
effort to see how they could downplay
the fact that the six million dollar
mansion
was there um they got caught lying about
this is uh
they got caught lying about its purpose
apparently so it was i think they called
it they called it like the center
or the high community center something
like that yeah six million dollar
mansion um and then they had everybody
sign ndas and then they sent uh private
investigators after the journalists that
were looking into it
but when you have a lot of
donations you're allowed to and one of
the things that was interesting this was
reported or one of the um
instigators for why this began becoming
investigated was because of some of the
local communities that were expecting
support from blm
had found that they weren't getting
support so you had people who were
struggling to make rent who were living
in these sort of impoverished
communities and stuff like that
and meanwhile yeah the original
director ceo somebody
has slipped out but still in her wake
there is a uh an aftershock of a six
million dollar mansion she has still
held on to five or so properties well
you need to
yeah i mean you've got to go from one
swimming pool to another it's easy to
get bored with one swimming pool uh this
is a this is a hustle and i mean if if
if if no one's did you call it black
lives racket black lives racket that's
right um one of my roles i write a
weekly column for the new york post and
um
we we ran a great front page on this
benighted um news emerged
i think posts were on the i think they
tried to come for the post actually on
exposing this
um
yeah i think these people are um i mean
you ask about motives and things and
this is the easiest one of course
uh on another mansion and another
mention uh um black lives mansions was a
fun
we ran um
only the post and uh
the
um yeah the the the
the impetus for these people is so
obvious so damn clear um and it's so
it's it's just it's such a it's such a
shame for so many reasons
you know they
like a lot of sort of charity like
things they have to present a situation
as being worse
than it is in order to maximize profits
and all the gay rights groups do that
now i mean i wish they'd all just shut
up and shut down and go home uh but they
don't they all they all
they've all got pensions and dress you
know
in invested interests these are all
vested interests and they they have to
all these groups and blms and classic
stuff we have to make the situation
appear worse than it is they have to
exaggerate the extent of racism in
america for instance in order to
maximize donations they then have to
mislead a load of perfectly sometimes
perfectly decent people not always into
handing over money they get corporations
to hand over effectively ransom money i
mean it's a sort of protection racket
you know awfully nice business you've
got the shame if anyone accused you of
racism
um
and uh and then you've got the the the
people who
um who were expecting to benefit and and
and don't benefit because the whole
thing was a hustle well
you know in america
we have a very clear um
sense of i say weeks we're sitting here
but um
of a certain type of pasta hackster you
know i remember this in the post the
other week you know they're the sort of
tammy faye baker sort of figures who who
you know um
they still go on a bit actually there's
one in texas still who saw you know they
like take out huge tv commercials and
they say you know you gotta hand over
your
your money because i just gotta have a
helicopter
i was in the car i was in the car
yesterday in an uber and i i've taken
since i've been here i usually listen to
classic fm uh to wake up on a morning
what i've found is that when i first
wake up if i listen to music i can't get
the song out of my head and sometimes
with classic fm this can be really
awkward because a lot of the music is
done to the same pace that i walk at and
that means as i'm walking down the
street i'm i'm creating the drum beat to
the song that i'm trying to get out of
my own head so out here i've taken to
listening to uh
keeping him close by
which is a local houston christian radio
station anyway got in the car yesterday
uber driver had a different
station on and they were doing a
60-second countdown
donation
drive
uh and saying you know
if if you feel moved
to submit this money then you can
you know it's it's going to help it is
there for a good reason i don't know and
then it was if they got
if this particular station that must be
part of a bigger network got more money
than the other stations that were
in different areas in the country on the
same network
maybe the presenters wanted a trip to
some i don't know but it just felt so
icky to me and that's you know that
that's being broadcast on the radio this
isn't you know the pastor huckster doing
it to a small town and that that was
that sort of commercializing of of
donations you know using a bunch of
psychological tricks a one-time offer a
countdown timer yeah this is click
funnels from 2006
you know with a oh and here's an upsell
for just another five dollars you can
get our free dvd course that you can
whatever whatever it's it's a bit of a
bit of a tangent i've got to say there's
no greater joy than for a british person
to just sit down and watch adverts on
american television uh i once some years
guys in
los angeles and i was watching a
television channel hopping and there was
a an advert from a local funeral home
a 999.99
[Music]
creation funeral all in
uh offer was only available for another
month
what what can you do with that i mean
granny
look
there's this amazing offer and i know
you're not well
this office is only on for another month
there is a long set of stairs if you
would if you were going to live another
five weeks you wouldn't be able to take
advantage of this magnificent offer
so
you know anyhow but the point is is that
yes we all know that type of huxter and
and and you know tin rattling maniac who
who who comes from a sort of certain
type of truth because they have a better
instagram page now right blm is is one
of those
i'm sad that it's taken this amount of
time
to be able to wake up to it i'm sorry
that they did become that you know they
could have been a civil rights
campaigning organization
campaigning for remaining
legitimate complaints of black americans
but they didn't do that they just became
another racquet even supporters of them
now or supporters of the movement have
started to distance themselves by using
two different terms right people talk
about black lives matter
to refer to the movement and they talk
about blm to refer to the organization
uh and as soon as you as soon as i
started to see that it's like yeah that
won't work that's a sign of um
internal uh dispute what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace